n'oubliez pas votre petit cadeau de
Noël de joyeuses fêtes pour tous à
Montini le Bretonneux la boutique
baliski accompagne chaque mois 50
familles adressé par des travailleurs
sociaux produits alimentaires ou
d'hygiène leur sont vendus à 50 % moins
cher que le prix en magasin pour
prolonger cette solidarité un colis
agrémenté d'articles de beauté et de
friandise est offert à chaque
bénéficiaire en cette fin d'année une
action grand cœur aussi pour les plus
jeunes l'association leur distribue des
jeux grâce à un don de la société asmodé
à Guill encour l'année dernière nous
avons une famille quand elles ont eu le
colis de Noël et qui avait les jouets
pour les enfants la maman a pleuré parce
qu'elle m'a dit je pourrais au moins
mettre des jouets sous le sapin de Noël
pour des enfants 21e siècle bon voilà
c'est là on se dit on a rempli notre
rôle il y a des puzzles il y a des
jouets pour les enfants des le Père Noël
n'oublie personne durant les deux
derniers weekends une grande collecte de
jouet était organisée dans les locaux de
l'association plaisiroise plaisir
solidarité poupée peluche ou camion de
pompiers pour le moment près de 80
articles ont été rassemblés grâce à une
dizaine de donateurs l'ensemble sera
remis à 100 enfants du quartier du
valiibou à l'issue d'un spectacle de
clown ce 28 décembre on a fait quatre
groupes fille et garçon et de 3 à 6 ans
et de 7 à 10 ans donc on va répartir les
jouets en fonction des trois groupes et
il y aura donc un tirage au sort par
l'enfant on l'appellera en fait et il
tirera au sort un numéro qui
correspondra à un jouet parce que ça
nous a paru difficile parce qu'il y a
des joues qui vont être plus bon que
d'autres ainsi de suite on a tous bah
des enfants qui grandissent et donc il y
a des jouets qui ne servent plus et qui
sont encore en bon état donc autant que
ça serve à d'autres c'est toujours beau
quand les enfants ils découvrent un
cadeau et qu'ils ont les yeux qui voilà
qui sont pleins d'étoiles l'association
plaisir solidarité espère étendre son
action à d'autres quartiers de la
commune l'année prochaine des opérations
à Saint-Quentin en Yveline pour ne
mettre personne de côté le soir de Noël
ça